well thank you so much for staying with
us here at 4 30 I'm Christian casidis
and I'm Kirsten Joyce Metro Police say a
opioid related deaths are on the rise as
availability of fentanyl has become so
widespread well Mary Jane beliesa shares
how people in the community are trying
to raise awareness and the help
available for those struggling with drug
addiction
Metro Police say fentanyl deaths are on
the rise as of Monday Metro Police
responded to six deadly overdoses in the
past 36 hours at least four of them they
say we're connected to fentanyl I
probably have taken cocaine with
fentanyl at times in my life I just
didn't know it and by the grace of God
I'm here to talk to you about it as a
recovering addict DJ ooch knows a
destruction drugs have on someone's life
and the people in it just last month
Metro officers also rushed in to save
three people on the brink of death due
to fentanyl you can see on the body cam
footage how officers didn't hesitate to
jump into action when I did get in
inside room 16 there was a citizen
inside there and she relayed the
information saying that these three
individuals were snorting what they
thought to be cocaine which ended up
being family Dr Timothy Eider a
psychiatrist with Nevada mental health
is seeing higher fentanyl cases in the
clients he's treating it's a more potent
drug and they're chasing that higher
high and so there are people who are
having specific fentanyl issues that
went after trying to use that particular
drug he says many treatment options are
available regardless of your inability
to pay as saving a life is always the
primary objective Nevada mental health
is one of the agencies in town who
provides resources for substance use
treatment there's another business we
work closely with healthy Minds has an
intensive substance use program that's
also tied in with drug court so we have
community members who want those
Services there's a ton of options for
all walks of life please if you're out
there and you're doing drugs give it a
rest because you don't know what's in
your drugs these days and it can be your
life
according to the Clark County coroner's
office more than 100 women and more than
200 men died from opioids in 2021